Brad Pitt we hear that he has gone on
the offensive in his divorce battle with
Angelina Jolie a source close to the
Jolie Pitt child custody dispute tells
et Brad volunteered to take a drug test
as a kind of preemptive strike in the
custody battle process that source also
says Pitt remains in LA and it's unclear
when he will see his children again Pitt
was supposed to walk the red carpet
tonight for the new documentary voyage
of time
he's the film's narrator in the universe
billions of years in the making
yesterday he backed out of the
appearance referencing his divorce drama
in a statement quote I'm currently
focused on my family situation and don't
want to distract attention away this
statement could really signal a shift in
strategy for Pitt there's been an
avalanche of leaks favoring Angelina and
up to now we haven't really heard much
from Brad also it's important to note
it's not attributed to F or an attorney
but Brad himself speaking of Brad
strategy we could learn a lot more soon
he faces a looming divorce deadline he
has 30 days from Angelina's filing to
file his response that leaves him just
21 days left meanwhile Angelina remains
in seclusion and it looks like her
security team is on high alert all this
amid a barrage of new divorce headlines
today's just release covers are a kind
of catch-up for the celebrity weeklies
Brad and Angie's divorce news broke last
Tuesday too late for the magazine's
Monday printing deadline and finally the
Aniston angle
Brad's divorce has renewed interest in
his marriage to Jennifer Aniston and
Courtney Cox has something to say about
that
we spoke to Jen's friends co-star
yesterday and Revlon's philanthropic
luncheon I feel like we're exacerbating
it but even talking about its installed
numbers
[Music]